Does the Movie Always Faithfully Represent the Book?
It does not seem easy to create an outstanding movie on the silver screen out of an outstanding book.
Sometimes, the movie is better than the book,...
...or at least as good as the book.
But other times, though the movie says "based on the story written by..."
...it is very different from the book, in a not - so - good way.
A good example is the movie "Starship Troopers".
My friend read the book with the same title.
When we were college students, it was announced that a movie was going to be made from this book.
And he was extremely excited and looked forward to the movie's release with great anticipation.
But when he saw the movie, he was very disappointed.
The book is science fiction,...
...but is thick on political discourse and philosophical hypothesis,...
...and discusses moral responsibilities to become a good member of modern society.
But the movie was shallow and did not touch on the deeper insights into life issues highlighted by the book.
Although there are many constraints a director faces when going from a book to a movie,...
...I think the biggest obstacle preventing a movie from faithfully representing the book it's based on, is the director himself.
Creative license to change the story is understandable,...
...but going overboard is sure to disappoint those who have read the book before seeing the movie.